Feuer in einer Unterkunft für
ukrainische Flüchtlinge offenbar war das
Brandstiftung in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
nördlich von Wismar ist das passiert ja
es geht um dieses Reetdachhaus vom Roten
Kreuz dort waren seit Monaten 14 Ukraine
untergebracht auch Kinder darunter und
jetzt eben ist diese Unterkunft komplett
niedergebracht
das ganze in groß strümkendorf das
zeigen wir noch mal auf der Karte das
ist nördlich von Wismar also dort an
einem oberen Zipfel von
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern direkt vor der
Insel Poel eine sehr ruhige und
idyllische Ecke Deutschlands
in der Gemeinde Groß strökendorf in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern haben mutmaßlich
brandstift eine Unterkunft für Ukraine
Flüchtlinge angezündet
lichterloh stiegen die Flammen in den
nächtlichen Himmel zerstörten fast das
komplette Gebäude was für eine
unfassbare Tat ich bin sehr erschüttert
wirklich berührt dass das hier
geschehen ist in der Region dass das
Gebäude jetzt in Vollbrand
niedergebrannt wurde
das Feuer war Mittwoch gegen 21 Uhr 20
an einer Außenwand am Haupthaus des
redgedeckten Hotelkomplexes schäfereck
ausgebrochen in dem Hotel waren seit
März dieses Jahres 14 Flüchtlinge aus
der Ukraine untergebracht unter ihnen
auch Kinder am Abend des Feuers waren
zusätzlich noch drei Mitarbeiter des
Roten Kreuzes vor Ort die Flammen
griffen Rasen schnell auf das Dach über
was sich sofort entzündete verletzt
wurde zum Glück niemand da ich zehn
Jahre auch Gemeindewehrführer war am
Brandort war saß für mich nach
Brandstiftung aus das muss ich ganz
deutlich so sagen weil da wo der Brand
entstanden ist ist sonst nichts und das
wie ich den augenscheinlich vorgefunden
habe springt es aus meiner Sicht für
meine Wahrnehmung für Brandstiftung
[Musik]
die Polizei geht eigenen Angaben zufolge
ebenfalls von Brandstiftung aus wie
konkret es zum Brand kam war zunächst
allerdings unklar als die
feuerwehreintraf versuchten bereits
Mitarbeiter der Einrichtung den Brand
mit Feuerlöschern zu bekämpfen die
Bewohner sind unmittelbar nach dem Feuer
in einer andere Einrichtung verlegt
worden so ich finde das sehr schreckend
dass man in dem Land ankommt wo man
denkt man ist im in der Sicherheit und
geschützt und plötzlich muss man wieder
mal sein Heim verlassen man muss wieder
mal um eigene Sicherheit bangen und
diese Unsicherheit erneut erleben diese
schon mal erlebt haben aus Angst
woanders hin zu fliehen das ist heute
leider auch passiert dass die aus
unserer Einrichtung in eine andere
Einrichtung in vollem Unwissen fliehen
sollten
der Feuerwehreinsatz dauerte noch bis in
die frühen Morgenstunden vor Ort waren
knapp 120 Einsatzkräfte und rund 20
Einsatzfahrzeuge
Reporter Michael Brockmeyer der ist für
uns vor Ort Michael wir haben es eben
schon im Beitrag auch gesehen
Flüchtlinge die eh schon alles verloren
haben zurückgelassen haben haben jetzt
das Bisschen was sie noch hatten auch
bei diesem Brand verloren wie geht es
diesen Menschen jetzt
ja die Menschen sind natürlich
traumatisiert 14 Flüchtlinge darunter
auch Kinder die hier heute Nacht in
diesem in dieser Unterkunft sich
aufgehalten haben die wurden geweckt
teilweise teilweise haben sie geschlafen
teilweise waren sie aber auch noch wach
es war ja erst 21:20 Uhr da hat er
Heimleiter quasi den Alarm mitbekommen
dann kam Passanten auf ihn zugelaufen
haben gesagt es brennt am Giebel dann
haben sie versucht eilig das zu löschen
das gelang ihn auch erst dann haben sie
die Feuerwehr alarmiert und ganz Uhr
plötzlich zog dann das Feuer durchs Dach
und das Gebäude stand innerhalb von
wenigen Minuten im Vollbrand die
Menschen konnten sich dann auf die
Straße retten haben das was Sie
mitnehmen konnten natürlich mitgenommen
und eben gerade hatte ich ein Gespräch
mit dem Geschäftsführer des drks hier in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern für die sozialen
Betreuungsdienste und der war wirklich
den Training nahe der war ganz toll ja
auch selbst traumatisiert von dem was er
hier erlebt hat heute morgen
Brandstiftung hieß es heute ganz schnell
ganz früh das haben wir auch gerade noch
mal in den Beitrag gesehen Michael was
deutet darauf hin und gibt es irgendeine
Spekulation oder auch Erkenntnisse über
ein Motiv bisher
gestern Abend hat die Polizei direkt 90
Minuten nachdem der Brand hier
ausgebrochen ist bereits vermeldet das
muss man aber ganz Verdacht davon
ganz kurz sagen während du sprichst
sehen wir gerade ein Foto vom Wochenende
da wurde nämlich genau an diese
Flüchtlingsunterkunft das Schild am
Eingang vom Roten Kreuz geschmiert wir
sehen das da wurde aus dem roten kreuzen
Hakenkreuz gemacht das nährt natürlich
jetzt Spekulationen über diese
Brandursache was weißt Du darüber
Michael entschuldige
ja das hat uns auch der
drk-geschäftsführer so eben bestätigt
das ist dieses Foto gibt dies gab diese
Straftat auch an diesem Objekt da war
tatsächlich ein Hakenkreuz aufgemalt
worden das war jetzt am Wochenende eine
Woche zuvor brannte bereits ein
Einfamilienhaus auch ganz hier in der
Nähe und natürlich man geht davon aus
und das hat die Polizei gestern Abend
auch direkt vermeldet wie gesagt eine 90
Minuten ungefähr nach Brand Ausbruch
bereits dass man hier von einer schweren
Brandstiftung ausgeht und natürlich wenn
hier
Personen im Gebäude sind dann reden wir
hier von einer schweren Brandstiftung
und dann wahrscheinlich auch von einer
politischen Straftat
Michaela wie geht es jetzt tatsächlich
weiter auch in der brand-ermittlung
welche Spuren verfolgen sie abgesehen
eben von diesem Hakenkreuz konntest du
da schon irgendwas in Erfahrung bringen
also es wird hier in Kürze in
Brandursachen Ermittler erwartet der
kommt hier vor Ort der geht dann durchs
Gebäude aktuell kann der hier noch gar
nicht durchs Gebäude gehen weil es
raucht noch es sind teilweise sogar noch
Flammen zu sehen das Gebäude ist
einsturzgefährdet also selbst die
Feuerwehr kann da gar nicht in dieses
Gebäude reingehen weil wenn da irgendwas
passiert da fallen Dinge runter der
Dachstuhl kann weiter einstützen die
Decken und so weiter das wäre einfach
viel viel zu gefährlich ich weiß auch
gar nicht ob der brandur Sachen Mittler
heute Mittag hier wirklich schon seine
Arbeit aufnehmen kann oder ob das erste
vielleicht auch erst morgen kann ja wir
sehen das hinter dir können wir noch mal
groß zeigen Michael wie wenig
tatsächlich von dieser Unterkunft von ja
diesem so idyllischen Reet gedeckten
Haus der übrig geblieben ist da stehen
ja wirklich nur noch die Mauern komplett
zerstört die Menschen dort sollen alles
was sie noch mitbringen konnten aus der
Ukraine verloren haben jetzt kannst du
uns was sagen über die Atmosphäre dort
ganz oben im Norden im
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern bezüglich dieser
Flüchtlingsunterkunft bezüglich
ukrainischen Flüchtling gab es Spannung
in den vergangenen Wochen Monaten
also der Herr Thilo rau der
Geschäftsführer des drks für diese
Betreuungsdienste in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern hat mir auch eben
gerade noch mal dass die Menschen hier
aufgenommen wurden die wurden herzlich
willkommen geheißen viele auch aus
diesem Dorf hier haben sich da engagiert
haben mitgemacht haben Feste organisiert
haben Lebensmittel und Sachspenden
gegeben also die waren schon sehr
engagiert das mit diesem Hakenkreuz das
war ja erst vor wenigen Tagen da ist
eine ganz neue Dimension die da jetzt
passiert ist da hat man noch gar keine
Erklärung für im Grunde Michael du
bleibst natürlich für uns dran an dieser
Geschichte Dankeschön für den Moment
[Musik]